in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Kevin
and Michelle are with us hey guys how
are ya hey good how are you better than
I deserve welcome to Nashville where do
you live Warren Michigan so just outside
Detroit very cool so how did you get to
Nashville Flyer Drive flaut because we
can afford that you know Ford it now I
know so how much debt have you paid off
we paid off fifty nine thousand dollars
how long did that take you thirty two
months cool
making what kind of money started at
eighty thousand and about ninety seven
thousand now haven't finished our taxes
though Congrats so what do you guys do
for a living I'm a real estate broker
and now I also have an office job at a
major automotive manufacturer okay and I
was in HR until we were able to cashflow
my school for real estate appraising so
now I'm doing that full-time Wow good
for you so both headed into the real
estate world yeah yep very cool
good how's the market in Detroit uh it's
it's up and down but you know it's it's
like everybody else right now we're
still trying to get over the get over
the fall but things are starting to come
back a little bit good very cool so what
kind of debt was the fifty nine thousand
dollars um it was a lot of credit card
debt some student loans and some medical
debt okay so you're kind of normal thank
you everything but a card that in there
just about yeah I had a personal loan
that had a lien on that car so okay how
long have y'all been married a year and
a half now oh so you've been doing this
before you got married yeah and then
while you've been married yeah okay so
tell me the story well it started with a
freak out at about two o'clock in the
morning that's a good honest that's a
good honest thing yeah I mean I had a
one credit card that I was spending
money I didn't have to impress somebody
I did like but and then she had debt and
I bought Total Money Makeover and it sat
on a shelf for about two or three months
and then she had a freaked out she
couldn't cover her bills and I should
read the book read the book read the
book read the book and finally she did
and I created a monster and now we
coordinator to you at our church Wow
yeah so we're we're all in we're all in
now I love it
very cool okay so you were the freaked
out then Michelle at two o'clock in the
morning that
me okay it's like oh my gosh oh my gosh
this is I'm suddenly overwhelmed I've
got the sweaty palms exactly the the
sweat a little bit on the upper lip I
remember that revealing when the
checkbook won't balance and I feel like
I've gone over and I thought oh my gosh
I don't screw this up again and it was
living just penny - penny paycheck to
paycheck and no fun at all and and so he
says read the book and it took you a
couple tries yeah and it took a couple
of tries for me to actually do it and
then I read it and I read it through it
in like a day I hustled and then I tried
to convince him to you to read it but he
also took some time to do that and then
once we'd once we did it we were both on
the same page and we just we really work
together to you know make a difference
and change our life so at what point did
you go through Financial Peace
University so we started in April of
2013 we did our first budget and we got
engaged in June of 2013 and then we said
you know it's part of our premarital
counseling for ourselves that we're
gonna go through financial piece and we
did that in September of 2013
okay so early in this process early on
yeah okay
but going through the book made you gave
you the wake-up call and made you think
you could do it yeah it was a makeover
book I guess yeah it was the stepping
off point really all right all right
so Michelle described two folks that
have not been through this like you have
what happened as you're going through
the Total Money Makeover book because
the information is not that particularly
new mm-hmm it's not like you said wow
that's hard to understand because
there's nothing in there that's not
there's nothing in there deep no but
what made you believe um well you know
you have to have that moment where you
are freaking out that you can't pay your
bills and and you really have to want to
make a change and I really did want to
make a change I wasn't happy with the
way I was living I wasn't happy with um
you know just working all the time and
you know and basically watching my money
go out you know the same hour I get paid
you know so it was just it was
frustrating enough in all the real world
examples inside the book really you know
made it more personal for me so that I
was able to really relate to it but it
was
it was a you know a moment in my life
where I needed to make it just make a
decision on what I wanted to do it was
kind of when the students ready the
teacher will appear thing hey oh so much
yeah that's happened so many times over
our journey too it's been crazy yeah
very cool very cool so she gets on fire
you create a monster Kevin and then
finally you reach over after she she's
bangs you over the head with this thing
said okay you got to read it and how
long was the time between Michelle
reading Total Money Makeover in Kevin
reading before the trying to get to the
I'm kind of fit one to feel out the
relational down that makes more than
more than a discussion of the book but
this is interesting right well I knew
about you because my my father was real
estate ELP and you know I thought I was
kind of doing Dave Ramsey and then I
read the book and I realized that still
wasn't um from the time she read it
until the time she finally got you to
read it was hello Montana okay
alright sounds like our house yeah okay
you need to read this you need to read
this yeah then I finally read it told
you dude rude that's what it sounds like
around our place so yeah I just finished
one I handed it to Sharon she finished
one handed it to me and this is the same
thing going on right now for a different
subject obviously but Wow very cool very
cool
so now you've done it I mean you did it
you worked it separately and but but
together and then he worked it
completely together for the last 18
months yep and you've led Financial
Peace University classes how's it feel
oh it's incredible it's life-changing
it's it's it's really amazing I'm so
excited to see what the future has in
store for us
yeah and it's it's it's been a ride cuz
we we had a lot of life go cuz we
cashflow at our wedding in the middle of
the Asher she actually had a car
accident that totaled the vehicle but it
was kind of a blessing in disguise
because we discovered that she gets I
read cancer and through having a next
scan and wow the whole time we're
worried that our little thousand dollar
emergency fund isn't going to sustain us
and we're trying to find crazy glue for
the you know for the credit cards but
thankfully and I mean I guess just our
faith in the program and everything just
seemed to appear out of nowhere it was
like we we decided to start going to the
church that we took a few at originally
in the next week I had that car accident
and I you know I was like oh boy you
know a month later I get the diagnosis
that I own I Roy cancer my that church
our church the woods Church and Warren
is amazing and they were so supportive
and so helpful and it was like we found
them at just the right time and that
accident happened at just the right time
so like you said you know when when I'm
ready the teacher will appear and and I
really think that God really spoke to us
and said you know what you're on the
right path all these things are gonna
happen in the right order Wow
so how are you now perfect yep just had
my year scan and I am cancer-free oh
praise God awesome very cool this is a
great story Wow
there's a lot going on here yeah was
throughout all of it though we never
touched that thousand dollars it was
amazing things just happened huh that's
neat
so when you're teaching financial piece
and someone comes in and they're having
that freakout moment what do you tell
them the secret is to getting out of
debt you have to it you have to work
together and you have to do your budget
and really stick to it we love our
budget night actually like sometimes we
do it outside and you know we just have
a great time with it because we budget
in our life and we get to go to dinner
and we get to do fun things it's not
it's not restrictive it's it's fun and
it's it gives you freedom and if you
really can step back from it and look at
it from that perspective
it'll change your life so the budget not
doing the budget is a big thing
obviously doing it together is a big
thing mm-hmm what would you add to that
Kevin um I think you just have to be
all-in on it you can't you can't half
way go through it and decide to do okay
the budget I mean that's it's cool on
paper and then just go around and do
whatever you want it's see you've got to
follow it you you've got it you've got
to decide that this is the way we're
going to live our life from this day
forward and stick to it that's important
you know it always tickles me because
being me obviously people say you know
I'm doing the Dave Ramsey thing you know
which is always kind of funny because
all it is is common sense right what
that means is it's code for I'm getting
out of debt I'm getting on a budget I'm
working together with my spouse I'm
using some dadgum common sense you know
and then I really think it's funny when
somebody says I'm sorta doing the
diagram
so that all in matters right absolutely
all right Kevin and Michelle Detroit
Michigan 59,000 paid off at 32 months
counted down let's hear a death free
scream three two one
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim